so i feel an obligation for us to talk
about portland
um the reason we talked a bit about
mayor wheeler having done something
unusual last time which is he
stood up and said uh that the anarchists
who are
breaking the windows of businesses and
setting fires and all have to be
in his words unmasked and arrested um
the anarchists came back this week and i
don't know the anarchists
but someone someone among the anarchists
a self-declared
uh member of antifa put out a video
uh in the style of anonymous
um but this was actually quite different
than any anonymous video i've seen
before zach do you want to uh
show it yeah
hello we come to use a small collective
from within the anarchist and
anti-fascist community do not speak for
the whole
as each individual may carry different
ideologies
and beliefs about how things could
should or will be accomplished we hope
with this message to simply convey a few
points that are commonly agreed upon
within this community
the mayor of this city is undeserving of
his position
he has made it abundantly clear that
windows to him
are more important than human life but
we are not just challenging the idea
of having ted as a mayor we are
challenging the idea
of having mayors at all we want
abolition
abolition is absolutely peaceful marches
speeches and voting were enough to bring
about that goal
then we would have already been there
window smashing
and riots are a necessary escalation
when those in power
have proven that they are unwilling to
listen and have made the choice
to ignore you we are moving with a sense
of urgency
because not only is the system
destroying us it's destroying the very
planet that we live on
this movement encompasses the liberation
of all those oppressed by the system
whether it be black
indigenous hispanic etc nobody owns this
movement
and wants who are trying to claim
ownership of this movement just leads to
more division which is counterproductive
to all of our goals we are on the same
side though
and the more time we spend fighting each
other the less energy we have to fight
the true enemy
so let's start local with our own city's
failed leadership
ted we are asking for the last time that
you resign
if you ignore this message outright the
destruction to your precious way of life
is going to escalate
blood is already on your hands ted but
next time
it may just be your own
okay so what you've just seen is a video
in which ted wheeler is
threatened at the end um and doxxed the
video that we showed had his
address uh blurred out but
but anyway this is quite serious stuff
to have
uh anarchists threatening your mayor and
police chief and i'm very much hoping
that that uh mayor wheeler will
stand his ground and i think that this
is evidence
that he needs to actually increase uh
his commitment even
beyond because obviously this is a
response to his saying that they need to
be unmasked and arrested
and if they're going to up the ante by
threatening public officials then
obviously
capitulation would be an insane thing to
do and
um you know anyway i hope he has the
courage to do what must be done
but the other thing is this has not been
widely reported
yeah and that i find absolutely stunning
there is a death threat made by a bunch
of anonymous thugs against a
sitting mayor of uh a major american
city
and they say if i remember correctly um
we are not just challenging the idea of
having ted wheeler as mayor we are
challenging the idea of having mayors at
all we want abolition
they just keep on saying it you know
they they're really not pretending
um and no this isn't the same you know
this this isn't the
thousands of people who were showing up
for the daytime protests
but this is some of the same people who
stuck around night after night
and you know the destruction downtown
has is experiencing a
renaissance and uh and you know and here
we go and into the middle of this into
the middle of this fray so
you um reported on
wheelers standing up to them saying that
they need to be unmasked and arrested
last week and in response uh one of our
city councilmen
um has chided him so here we have from
willamette week which is our uh
local free news weekly heartisty joe and
hardesty is the council person in
question hardesty says wheeler must hold
police accountable if he wants an end to
destructive marches
in chiding wheeler hardesty waded into
an ongoing civic debate about portland
policing
and the nighttime protests by a group of
roughly 100 leftists
so i will say that that you know that
sub-headline in particular is just
full of um i would say
beyond imprecise but inaccurate language
as well
nighttime protests ongoing civic debate
um she chiding him um and i used that
word when i was introducing this but
here we go just the first paragraph
portland city commissioner joanne
hardesty issued a measured rebuke
that's more accurate wednesday to mayor
ted wheeler's call for a crackdown on
black block marchers who smash windows
saying the city shouldn't expect peace
until it disciplines police officers who
thrashed protesters last summer
this is a city a sitting city
commissioner who says the city
in which she has a seat should not
expect peace
until police officers who thrashed
protesters last summer are disciplined
now
i am unaware of thrashing
that happened and there will be plenty
of people who say oh here's a video here
like
you know what we covered this in more
detail than i care to
um but i am i am not compelled
that the portland police or the um
the feds when they were allowed to be
here um
did thrashing here in portland
i am not compelled yeah no and of course
everything here is turned on its head
cause and effect wise this was going on
long before
blm protest long before george floyd yes
um you know and i think again this week
uh
the anarchist wait wait what was going
on long before george
the anarchist in the pacific northwest
uh
right but but this wasn't no no this is
not going on this is new but my point is
the idea
that the precipitating event is the
thrashing of the anarchists by
police is absurd especially in the
larger context and
you can see this in the fact that when
we arrived in portland
they were already periodically taking
over intersections
and um what would the term be harassing
drivers threatening them it happened
again this week
so the point is this is the same old
same old being portrayed in a context
that generates sympathy on some fronts
but you know
the smart people aren't buying it
you